And I'd like to talk about another pattern that's very common when designing
classes. We'll say that the class has a property if it has a value that one can
simply get and set. Look at a person, a person has a name. That's a private
instance variable, so we'll have a getter that returns the name and here we
have a setter that you can use to set the name to a new name incase the person
for whatever reason is unhappy with the previous one. It's very very common to
have this pattern instance variable getter setter there some variations
sometimes you do some error checking in the setter here we check that the new
name, is not the empty string, cause no one's name should be the empty string.
Or, maybe, in a particular application it just shouldn't be allowed to change
the name, in that case, there wouldn't be a setter. This is a read only
property in this example where we just have, the instance variable and the
corresponding getter. Now, properties, meaning private instance variables with
getters and maybe setters are very common. But that doesn't mean that you
should make every instance variable a property with a getter and setter. Only
use the getters when there is a need for the user of the class. To read the
instance variable and only supply a setter when there is a need for the user to
modify it, many instance variables do not have getters and setters. Well let's
practice that with yet another variation of the car class, this car class has a
number of instance variables and I'd like you to look it over and add getters
and setters for those where it's appropriate, and not add them for those where
it's not.